please welcome Owen Wilson and Ben
Stiller
are you doing yeah why aren't you in
your hutch other I don't know I just I
just saw look a little goofball ish is
your idea I know I know I feel bad I
just decided that you know it's kind of
bad taste to come out here and plug your
movie it's a little shameless it's okay
that Billy Crystal came at 1:00 you're
riding a horse for city slickers band
he's Billy Crystal
okay he built this freaking house you
look good you look good you look cold
you okay
okay um the nominees for best live
action man what up up it's their moments
not your moment to power come on see
Academy Awards it's not the Ben Stiller
I made a mistake now everyone has to pay
a woman the nominees for Best live
action short are d rota Yakka the red
jacket florian box meyer most the bridge
Bobby Garabedian and William Zabka
squash Leonel bayou
a torsion a torsion Stefan arsenyevich
two soldiers Aaron Schneider and Andrew
J sacks and the Oscar goes to two
soldiers
Aaron Schneider and Andrew J style this
is the first Academy Award AB nomination
for Aaron Schneider Andrew J sighs
oh man this is amazing Billy Crystal I
bet you don't remember recommending film
school to a 20 year old kid wondering
what to do with his life about 18 years
ago thank you for that thank you to the
Academy like to thank our cast Jonathan
fer as parents David and Janet Ben
Allison Ron Perlman David Andrews and
the rest of our cast our crew Kate
Miller Betsy [ __ ] Bob you say David
Boyd see Robert Holloway Kelly Matsumoto
Alonzo Wilson the amazingly generous
Alan Silvestri Joe Roth for a 10-second
grace period on the speech clock please
Craig and Lisa May Fincannon Scott
Gerson Melissa Hoffman Stan Lee Johnston
Rebecca Clark the NCSA school of
filmmaking brian Spruill michael's Acula
Bev would seal Dubinsky Phil Raiden the
lovely and talented Marc Shaiman down
there somewhere please for coming in
late on this next music cue Leon
Silverman John Stern Howard Anderson Lee
Kaplan Jill Falkner summers in our
American treasure will in Faulkner who
wrote to soldiers in 1942 after the
first unprovoked attack on the United
States it's the story of two brothers
who fight to preserve their family and
country like a siblings love a soldier's
devotion is selfless and unconditional
and need not concern itself the politics
of war I dedicate this to my family and
the soldiers protect our loved ones and
the freedoms we celebrate
okay the nominees for best animated
short film here's what you do you change
clothes for the party that's where all
the presses will be fine no you know I
don't want to change them happy with how
I look I think I look good and gonna
wear it all night okay we're tomorrow
wear it all week big name maybe I will
not out of the question
Oh sexy weeks okay nominees for best
animated short film are
bounden but lucky destino dominique
montre and roy edward Disney
gone nutty carlos saldanha and Jhansi
duncan harvey crumpet Adam Elliot
nibbles Chris Hinton
and the Oscar goes to
Harvey crumpet Adam Eliot
this is the first Academy Award at
nomination for Adam Ellie
well Harvey crumpet has been a film
that's been in my head for over 10 years
and I'm so glad he's out we'd like to
congratulate everyone in Australia who
helped Harvey come to life in particular
the Australian Film Commission film
Victoria and SBS independent Harvey will
be screening on SBS television next
Monday night at 9:00 p.m. I would also
like to congratulate our fantastic cast
and crew especially our uncle geoffrey
rush for lending us his most beautiful
voice finally we'd like to thank a very
good two very very special people
my friend juliet and my beautiful
boyfriend dan thank you i'd like to
congratulate my mother Margaret Harris
to live in the hearts of others not to
die and you'll always be in my heart
we'd like to thank the Academy thank you
so much